michael bay went out of his mind he was
like you can't do that you know because
i would do all kinds of crazy things i
said i said without this toys there's no
movie i said there's no michael bay i
said you know for pearl harbor i said
but this is this is what it's about
do the right thing
pino get a broom and sweep up front
[Music]
get a broom sweep out front huh get a
broom and sweep out front
get a broom and sweep out front i grew
up uh in hollis queens which was
predominantly a black neighborhood and i
moved to kind of a more of a white
neighborhood then i got bust out to a
all black junior high school later on so
a lot of the the film spoke to me and
and i remember i liked the script a lot
when i met spike he was very quiet and
he said you know what part do you like i
said
i said i think because of the subject
matter of it i i'd rather play uh you
know the racist part because that's you
know i i know where some of those people
are coming from you know having grown up
in a black community then going to a
white community and
and kind of feeling some of that
prejudice even you know even towards me
bob i don't believe this [ __ ] you're
running welfare or something
every day you give this a pep a dollar
what's your pet what is
so when you would watch me say these
things
over and over again
sometimes people would think well that's
that's who he really is and there was a
girl who was on craft services and she
uh
she used to pass me by with the water
and one day i said you may have a glass
of water and she turned she told me she
said i
you know i hate you she said you know i
hate you so much
is not to be trusted i trust him
no no moving on can be trusted
the first time you turn your back boom
the spear right here man in the back and
spike was just very collaborative you
know me and richard fighting in
wrestling that was something that
we we came up with on you know on the
day you know uh to have a contradiction
your physical contradiction and you're
trying to kill your brother i mean
saying you know i love you listen to me
you know i mean but there was a lot of
uh laughter and fun and
all kinds of stuff in that until we got
to the end of the movie which was not so
much fun to do
but it was a lot of energy on that set
it had a different kind of vitality to
it because people hadn't gotten to tell
a lot of their stories and we
was very exciting to do something that
was about something i did think there
was something
palpable about it that's all i that's
all i knew when i saw the first
screening i was like holy moly i was and
then you know when the film came out
there a lot of people thought there was
going to be riots in the theater and
people
you know be violence and uh
it was just the opposite none of that
ever happened but it kind of cemented my
friendship with spike he grew up in
italian neighborhood i grew up in a
black neighborhood he saw that i would
try to create a whole human being who
was that way and not just you know
a flat
cardboard cutout a representation of
that
the big lebowski
[Music]
so
[Music]
you know i had no idea the movie would
be as funny as it was and i even didn't
even get the movie when i saw it the
first time i was like
some of it went over my head it was
until later on that i realized how it's
a religious film it's sort of a
existential philosophy concept said that
he was inspired in part by they saw even
a play yeah what was the story the play
was the play was called la puta vida by
ronaldo provide and i played a character
that was called chino and it was very
close
you know like a cousin and that's why
when i did the movie later on
sort of a sequel
of the jesus i was really thinking about
that particular play so i i loved that
character when i did it on stage i liked
when i did the sequel and
so when it was a little part
and i said wow what am i going to do
with this and i said well you'll come up
with some stuff and we're going to give
you some extra time and they did so you
know when you you're on for a little
short time you have to like really make
it count you pull any of your crazy [ __ ]
with us you flash a piece out on the
lanes
i'll take it away from you and stick it
up your ass and pull the [ __ ] trigger
till it goes
click jesus
you said it man
nobody [ __ ] with the jesus so uh but i
didn't realize they would put it
together that way when i saw it i was
embarrassed the first time i have to say
but it's a character that i love yeah i
i could just
i mean i could have a talk show as to
jesus you could have all different
people on like tom brady
what's happening tom man why'd you
retire [ __ ] you know
i want to know i want to know what's
going on man you know i could have been
way better quarterback than you man
yeah because i had the finger man
[Music]
barton thing
did you
somebody just complained no i didn't i
mean i i did call down not to complain
exactly
really fun fun fun shoot i got to work
with so many great actresses john
goodman tony chalu michael lerner john
polito i spent a lot of time in prep
with joel and ethan rehearsing with them
reading with them talking about it
well i don't mean to get up on my high
horse
but why shouldn't we look at ourselves
up there
who cares about the fifth earl of
bastrop and lady higginbotham and
and who killed nigel grinch gibbons i
could feel my butt getting sore already
it was challenging and it was a
lot of uh fun to you know attempt you
know i was writing stuff while they were
filming me
and because i was watching films about
writers and i did never look like they
were writing anything and we didn't they
didn't know exactly how everything would
play too they they i said one day they
said oh you're making it much more
horribly human than we imagined then i
was like well that's kind of my job i
is my think
this is how i serve the common man this
is where i feel
[Music]
miller's crossing
they said they were writing this part
for me for a couple years and took them
a long time and in the middle they wrote
part and think when they had writer's
block
get to the point huh okay the point is
i'm a good guy i've heard up a lot of
people today good guy lots of friends
that's the way it works maybe if you
appreciated me a little more you
wouldn't be making waves with leo you
know when someone's giving gives you
that much then your feeling is well i
want to surprise them and do something
even more than maybe they imagine and
that's how i've always felt
working
with joel anything and the two of the
nicest people the most
humane people you know i've ever worked
with and so i would
what i would do for them i wouldn't
necessarily be able to do for other
directors
[Music]
i had a picture of leopold and loeb and
i said this is how i want to look i
interviewed a lot of people
i had them do the lines for me
in yiddish and
in english so
yeah i really put a lot of uh work into
it and
they gave me
plenty of freedom in how i attacked it
but because it was so specific the look
and everything i i felt very very free
scratch huh
what bonus
what did make tech rugs have that beat
to me the kid was dizzy
50 50 on the doll or or maybe i should
get a little more since i did the deed i
think
when you know someone
has written something for you or
whatever you just feel like wow they
believe in me and
it's unsaid the things
in relationships that are really deep
are are not said they're not given words
it's like if you really love someone
can't keep saying to them hey i love you
it's what you do
quiz show
i was with redford a long time in prep
so i had all this footage i met the real
her but gained a lot of weight which
made me sick later on but i had a
wonderful time working with robert
redford he was a terrific
director and
we really got along really well and he's
from the theater and we we spoke the
same
uh language well it's a danish thing
would you plateaued
plateau
what kind of word is that
well plateaued plateau plateau uh it's
well it's like uh you mean people don't
like me anymore i did gain a lot of
weight but my teeth were discolored my
hair was thinned and someone came on the
set one day told redford like wow john
looks very different
kind of like let himself go a little bit
he just loved that you know he thought
that was the greatest thing ever and
redford really
got a kick out of what i was you know
doing and the whole crew used to do my
warm-up because i used to try to get
my voice very high well uh for example
he told me how to breathe heavily into
the microphone and sigh
such as this
he told me how to stutter and say in a
plane of voice i will take uh nine uh
nine points i used to have to go you
know
my um whole crew used to do this whole
thing but i would do the whole mask
warm-up to get
my voice which is not normally
that high you know to uh but uh herb had
this particular kind of voice you know
you you take what you can from the
person then you have to make them your
own but herb was so unique
and there was so much great stuff to
mine you know that's part of the fun of
it
[Music]
oh brother where art though
[Music]
crazy movie and
you know learning to play the mandolin
and they told me not going to do the
mandolin and this and that and you know
i had
learned an accent and then i and then i
had to get fake teeth and had my head
shaved and i got him i had a ball doing
it and uh once again the film did pretty
well because of the album but people
were like obsessed with it you watch it
again and again it's such a funny movie
i've always wondered
what's the devil look like
well of course they're all manner of
lesser amps and demons pete but the
great satan himself is red and scaly
with a bifurcated tail he carries a hay
for when you work with those guys they
know what they're doing they know what
they want every little thing counts you
know sometimes we wouldn't know what to
do in the scene
and ethan would tell me to to show my i
had all these rotten teeth this you know
lower teeth and he would just say show
your teeth you know get that kind of
teeth like that you know and i walked
around all day like i talked about that
the entire day i would try it out on
people i would talk to people a lot you
know and uh they would talk back to me i
was thinking all right well they believe
it so uh you know
you stole from my kin
who was fixing to betray us you didn't
know that at the time
so i borrowed it till i did know that
don't make no sense
i mean some things are like so cartoony
it's different but some things are are
larger than life but there are people in
life
that are larger than life not everyone
you know
talks like this in a movie
and that's one of the things that
sometimes gets me because i can't
understand
what they say
you know what i mean a lot of young i
can't understand i can't hear them
no maybe i'm getting old i'm getting
deaf but i'd like to be able to hear
what
the [ __ ] you're saying but sometimes in
a movie like that if you were being very
ultra naturalistic it would not register
i've also done a lot of theater so it's
not a big deal for me to say okay go
from here to here but should i go to
there
you know within it but it depends where
the camera is stage you learn how to
sustain a whole entire performance
and you are the editor because you know
when people are falling asleep and you
have to shift gears constantly so you're
like a more of a maserati you know where
you're a piecemeal worker in a film
you're doing it
you you're
you're moment hunting
transformers
i was
offered a lot of big-budget movies a lot
of them and i turned them all down i
used to do medium small plays sometimes
on the advice of my kids too uh i would
give them a script they would say it
isn't no not good
they said don't even read it just do it
and so i did big guys big guys with big
guns what is sector seven
answer me i'm gonna ask questions around
here not you young man how did you know
about the aliens where did you take my
parents i am not at liberty to this
disgusting hey i had a lot of fun
working with michael bay i think
michael's really i think kind of aped
his energy you know was it was
exhausting because it's not like
the most nuanced work it's sort of like
a
bold action painting or a sketch you
know
but within that i did enjoy his uh
you know his energy and and i liked
working with gyre
anyway mr nbe1 here aka megatron
that's what they call them it's pretty
much the harbinger death wants to use
the cue to transform human technology to
take over the universe i mean i used to
laugh because you know there was nothing
to look at you know like was a
microphone you would go oh my god it's
you know you know
it's prime it's it's optimus prime my
god you know and they would let me
improvise all the time and i was like
well don't you guys get a lot of money
to write these kind of scripts
bill big fan great to be here now agent
simmons you would have us believe that
it is in our best interest to formally
take sides in this so-called alien civil
war well the other side wanted to spank
us for breakfast so i wouldn't exactly
call it a toss-up
i had all the stunt men get me all the
original toys which i knew about you
know so i took it out in a shot and i
said they said it was a toy you know
i said but then i transformed it you
know into the truck i said but now we
know it's bad you know it's not it's
real and michael bay went out of his
mind he was like you can't do that you
know because i would do all kinds of
crazy things i said i said without this
toys there's no movie i said there's no
michael bay i said you know for pearl
harbor i said but this is this is what
it's about i think that kind of uh
spirit is essential when you do
something like that you have to be like
a five-year-old in a way
when they play you know five-year-olds
they're serious
night of
i mean those are two of the best writers
you know richard price and steve zalian
and i had a lot of time to prepare i met
a lot of lawyers and courts and there's
a lawyer kenny montgomery who was very
very helpful to me the material was rich
and
i felt like
my connection to riz was very
organic your man is here as it were
johnny the red
buy now
and don't lose that key
25 years the berlin wall comes down and
this throwback's still going on about
communists
so
i know bill camp you know genie berlin i
thought but steve's casting with av
kaufman was great it was about something
that is a big problem
you know i mean rikers island is bigger
problem now than it was then and what
happens you know to people when they
enter that system you know any system
you see
the pros and cons
and the nuances of it and the little
deaths that happen
within it and so
just a great car you know it's a great
was a great character too great
character i brought you some clothes
that you can collect them after
did your folks put some money in your
account uh no i don't think they knew to
well i'll make a deposit for you you
need money in here
how you doing
okay and i wanted to do another
even a different case with it but
we've never been able to agree
not me they have you know on like what
that case would be or whatever but i
loved working on it i really did it was
one of those you know experiences that
you just felt like it's all there you
know i had enough time to know it
backwards and forwards
a batman
i love you know filmoir and all that
stuff but
you know those kind of people
who last
whether they're
politicians
whether they're businessmen
whether they're gangsters who become
businessmen you know they're the person
who's like lives in the subterranean
world you know and they are the person
behind the screen who pulls all the
strings and
also
figures out people's vulnerabilities
and once they find that vulnerability
and once that person needs help they
come in as this altruistic person
this benefactor and then all of a sudden
you're in their debt and they own you
and matt wanted it very grounded and
everything and uh so that's what i was
sort of attempting and you know i've
been around
enough people
growing up my dad was in the building
line and i saw some of these people up
close and uh
you know there was something that was
really my father used to say don't look
in
this one particular person's eyes he
said don't look in his eyes
if he talks to you just look away
because there was something kind of dead
and seductive
at the same time so i thought you know
that could be something you know
interesting i mean i'm a batman fan i've
been a batman fan since i've been a kid
and
amadeo my oldest works for dc comics and
resident batman expert so matt was just
very you know collaborative and i liked
working very much with robert and with
zoe very much is there a specific kind
of logic or philosophy that you have
when choosing roles
i mean looking for things that you know
that you haven't done
you know you're looking
to not do something that you think you
could do